Before we attempt our problem, let's review mixed numbers and improper fractions.
Mixed numbers are a way to count objects when we have a couple of objects and a
part of that object. So here I have 2 doughnuts and then I have 2 thirds of one.
I can think about splitting up a whole doughnut into 3 equal pieces, or thirds,
and then I'd have 2 thirds. So our entire mixed number would be 2 and 2 thirds.
Notice we have a mixture of whole numbers and fractions. That's why we call
these mixed numbers. If I split all of my donuts up into thirds, I can count the
pieces and I would have 8 thirds, that would be the improper fraction. It's
improper because the number in the numerator is higher than the number in the
denominator. So, let's see how we can go from the mixed number to the improper
fraction. If I take my whole doughnuts, and split them up into thirds, I would
have six of them. 6 3rds.
I can get that by multiplying 3 times 2. I still have 2 3rds left over. So I
need to add this 2 3rds to my 6 3rds. 6 plus 2 makes 8, so I get 8 3rds.
Let's try going the other way. I can think about splitting 8 3rds into 6 3rds
and 2 3rds. Notice that the 6 3rds represents my two whole doughnuts. I know 6
divided by 3 makes 2, and then I have my 2 3rds left over. So 2 and 2 3rds. This
also makes sense because I know 3 goes into 8 two full times, and then I would
have a remainder of 2 or 2 3rds left over.